si padeces síndrome coronario agudo
tiene una o más afecciones provocadas
por el bloqueo del flujo sanguíneo hasta
el músculo cardíaco esta es una
emergencia médica ya que posiblemente
tenga un ataque cardíaco una afección en
la que el músculo cardíaco comienza a
morir
su corazón es un órgano muscular que
bombea la sangre que contiene el oxígeno
y los nutrientes que su cuerpo necesita
y la cámara de bombeo principal del
corazón es el ventrículo izquierdo
cuando el ventrículo izquierdo se
contrae envía sangre rica en oxígeno al
cuerpo a través de una gran arteria
llamada aorta
hay pequeñas arterias conectadas a la
aorta denominadas arterias coronarias
y la sangre fluye desde la aorta a
través de las arterias coronarias para
suministrarle oxígeno y nutrientes a su
músculo cardíaco si padeces síndrome
coronario agudo el flujo de sangre a
través de las arterias coronarias se
reduce gravemente o se bloquea por
completo
una causa posible del flujo sanguíneo
reducido es la arterosclerosis
en esta afección hay una acumulación de
una sustancia grasa denominada placa que
estrecha las arterias coronarias si esta
placa se rompe se puede formar un
coágulo sanguíneo y bloquear la arteria
la causa más común del bloqueo de la
arteria coronaria es un coágulo
sanguíneo
otras causas más comunes de la reducción
del flujo sanguíneo incluyen espasmo de
arteria coronaria o disección
en un espasmo arterial coronario algunos
detonantes como las drogas el cigarrillo
el clima frío y el estrés o las
emociones extremas pueden ocasionar un
endurecimiento temporal y repentino de
una arteria coronaria
durante una disección arterial coronaria
la pared interna de las arterias
coronarias se separa lo cual puede
bloquear el flujo sanguíneo
independientemente de la causa un
bloqueo en cualquier arteria coronaria
impide que el oxígeno y los nutrientes
de la sangre lleguen a la parte del
corazón suministrada por la arteria
como resultado el músculo cardíaco en
esa área comienza a morir la muerte de
una parte del músculo cardíaco se
denomina un ataque cardíaco también se
conoce como infarto de miocardio
y emme
es posible que una arteria coronaria
bloqueada también le haga sentir un
dolor repentino incomodidad
endurecimiento o sensación de quemazón
en el pecho denominada angina este dolor
puede extenderse a la parte superior del
abdomen los hombros brazos el cuello y
la parte inferior de la mandíbula
si padece angina cuando está en reposo o
una angina frecuente que impide incluso
la actividad física moderada padece
angina inestable que es el síntoma
principal de síndrome coronario agudo
y otros síntomas del síndrome coronario
agudo incluyen dificultad para respirar
mareo náusea y sudoración
si tuvo un ataque cardíaco o tiene otros
tipos de síndrome coronario agudo es
posible que su médico le recete terapia
de oxígeno para incorporar más oxígeno
en la sangre
puede tomar aspirinas u otros fármacos
anticoagulantes de venta bajo receta
para evitar la formación de coágulos
sanguíneos los trombolíticos también
conocidos como fármacos rompe coágulos
pueden usarse para romper los coágulos
sanguíneos existentes
y los fármacos como la nitroglicerina y
la morfina relajan las arterias
coronarias y alivian el dolor de la
angina
posiblemente también reciba fármacos
llamados beta bloqueadores que
ralentizan su corazón y reducen su
necesidad de oxígeno
su médico también podría recomendarle
procedimientos quirúrgicos inmediatos
por ejemplo una angioplastia coronaria
en la que un catéter con punta de globo
infla el interior de la arteria
coronaria bloqueada para abrirla después
de inflar la el catéter con globo deja
un dispositivo similar a una malla
denominado stent para mantener la
arteria abierta
o posiblemente se le coloque un injerto
de bypass de la arteria coronaria
hace el ibc es un procedimiento
quirúrgico en el cual se realiza un
bypass en las áreas bloqueadas de las
arterias coronarias con venas o material
de injerto artificial
si tiene síntomas de síndrome coronario
agudo busca tratamiento de inmediato